I am thinking about death a lot, whether it is my sister's suicide and my question about what happened to her,
Or just a theoretical for people around me and my knowledge that we are all temporary,
- "O hell, there is an insect in the water" - "One day, we will all become an insect in water"
Or ask me how I will die.
"Know when you can go to your home ..."
"Just for fun."
"This is the last face I will see."
I think the awareness of death helps you to truly live because it puts everything in your perspective.
Do not care about small things too much, encourage you to do what you really want to do,
You begin to measure your happiness relative to your experiences, and how satisfied you are with your relationships.
Of course it is sometimes more than bear and lead you to lie down on your bed
She wonders about the meaning of all this, but it has affected my life in beautiful ways.
Thinking about death made me feel more present
Because it is a reminder that you can not guarantee tomorrow.
It makes me want to be a more sympathetic and generous person
Because when you have the idea of ​​your death you should ask yourself:
What impact do I want to leave in this world?
How do I want to measure my values ​​and what will make my life meaningful?
And to know how I am not permanent and small compared to the greatness of the universe
Somewhat I have come to a conclusion that I consider my life successful
If you make a meaningful and inspiring art for people, if you help as many animals and people as possible,
And whether I have an emotional relationship that is full of love with my friends and family.
The manic intensity of death at a young age prompted me to make a philosophy about life,
And I encourage you to do the same thing.
Is just one sentence you can follow throughout your life, is like your expression of a hypothesis
Or logo that is in line with you you can refer to it time after time when
Life's tricks fool you into thinking you're going to be lost forever.
But you will not.
My slogan, which he used for 15 years, is "I love, so I am."
Let me know what is the philosophy of your life, I would love to hear it
I'm Okana, stay ...
Here is a cartoon letter made accurately by Miss Bethany Ruddoff of SpaceSpace.
I want to thank Square Space for taking care of the episode today.
Square Space has beautiful award-winning wallpapers in the system "All in One." There are no updates or repairs at all.
They have 24-hour customer service that you can call from any life after death.
If you do not have an account, do not worry, they provide an easy and unique start-up system.
And you can use "Square Space" in the work of any kind of sites,
Whether you are an artist, a photographer, or a life-reaper promoting your inevitable services.
Go to SquareSpace.com to start your free trial today and use the "Anna" promotion code to get a 10% discount on completion
"Square Space", we will all die.